Trascrizione: Federica Bruno
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che cos'è un'idea?
Beh, io potrei definire l'idea
come un meccanismo della mente umana,
atto a riconfigurare
gli elementi della propria conoscenza
in una veste originale.
Oppure, più romanticamente parlando,
mi piace pensare all'idea
come a un'"Isola del Tesoro"
da ricercare dopo una tratta
in acque inesplorate e immense.
Perché, di fatto,
se l'Isola del Tesoro è l'idea,
allora il viaggio verso
la validazione di questa idea
in pratica non è altro
che un percorso di sperimentazione.
Il mio intervento oggi si intitola:
"Viaggio nelle perigliose acque
della sperimentazione musicale".
In altre parole, parleremo di perigli
che in italiano moderno
significa pericoli.
Ogni viaggio all'avventura che si rispetti
non può che iniziare
da una mappa del tesoro:
che tradizionalmente ha
un punto di partenza,
una X rossa a indicare il Tesoro;
e un percorso tratteggiato
che si snoda nella pergamena.
Se ci pensate, la visione, l'idea
non è altro che una mappa,
ovvero: avere una fotografia chiara
di dove si vuole arrivare a parare;
sapere dove si parte;
e poi iniziare a pianificare un percorso
che subirà dei vari cambiamenti di rotta
ma ci porterà, verosimilmente,
auspicabilmente, alla meta.
Di fatto, una volta che abbiamo
pianificato il nostro percorso,
sappiamo chi siamo e dove vogliamo andare,
non ci resta che metterci nelle condizioni
di raggiungere la nostra meta;
e, per fare questo,
dovremo arruolare un equipaggio.
Arruolare un equipaggio può essere
un'impresa facile o difficile,
in virtù del capitano che siete.
Se voi siete il capitano facoltoso
che può entrare nella taverna
con due borse di denaro,
sbatterle sul tavolo e pagare i marinai,
Beh, molto probabilmente avrete
la fila di marinai
che vorranno arruolarsi con voi.
Se parimenti siete il capitano
che ha già ottenuto tanti tesori
e ha già vinto diverse avventure,
beh, allora anche
in questo caso avrete fortuna.
L'ipotesi un po’ più sfortunata, diciamo,
è quella in cui voi siete una sorta
di Jack Sparrow dei tempi moderni:
quindi un capitano un po’ squattrinato,
dalla reputazione fumosa;
beh, in questo caso è più difficile
perché ai vostri marinai dovrete chiedere
di seguirvi sulla fiducia
e, per fare questo,
dovrete essere molto bravi
a prendere la vostra visione,
metterla su pergamena
e mostrarla agli altri.
Quindi avrete in questo modo
preso la visione,
l'avrete resa un progetto comune.
Una volta preso il mare,
con il nostro equipaggio,
dovremo però fare attenzione
che a un certo punto parte di questo,
o l'intero equipaggio,
non faccia ammutinamento.
E l'ammutinamento può avvenire
per diverse ragioni:
la principale è la frustrazione.
La vostra idea, il vostro progetto,
è lungo da realizzare:
impiega settimane, mesi.
Qualcuno potrebbe mollare la spugna,
tanto più se gli orizzonti di successo
non sono ben definiti.
Oppure, qualche capitano riesce
a cooptare i vostri marinai,
pagandoli di più;
o per ragioni familiari,
o anche per ragioni strategiche.
Perché di fatto, l'equipaggio
non è composto soltanto
dagli stretti collaboratori;
ma da tutti quegli intermediari
che stanno tra voi, il vostro progetto -
la vostra canzone nel mio caso -
e il vostro pubblico.
L'idea dev'essere comunicativa:
non soltanto per gli utenti finali
ma anche per tutta la filiera
che poi vi accompagnerà
agli utenti finali appunto.
A me diciamo che è capitata
una situazione un po' di stallo,
un mezzo ammutinamento da parte
di alcuni intermediari, i media,
che magari, facendo parte
alcuni giornalisti
di una vecchia guardia, di una certa età,
insomma pensarono che il mio progetto,
che si trattava di un app album,
ovvero la prima licenza SIAE
per un album divulgato sotto forma
di applicazione per telefonini
e tra l'altro mixato in 3D audio
per cuffie auricolari,
quindi con diversi tratti
di comunicazione,
pensarono che il dover andare
su uno store digitale,
scaricare l'applicazione
sul telefonino, installarla,
inserire un jack di auricolari
e sentirsi un'ora e un quarto
di musica in questa modalità
diciamo che fosse
un pochino troppo laborioso.
E quindi, nel mare magnum
dell'offerta musicale,
che ogni giorno arriva
sulle loro scrivanie,
perdere tutto questo tempo
per un'emergenza
era un'operazione un attimino,
diciamo, sconveniente;
e come dargli torto.
L'ammutinamento può fermare un progetto:
nel mio caso non l'ha fermato,
ma può anche arrivare
a stoppare un'avventura.
Tuttavia, non è l'unico pericolo
che si può incontrare nel mare.
Perché a un certo punto,
potrebbe spuntare fuori
la famigerata bandiera nera
con il teschio dei pirati.
E qua c'è anche poco da fare metafore,
perché i pirati sono, tradizionalmente,
coloro i quali derubano.
In questo caso derubano l'idea,
la realizzano prima di voi
e vi bruciano ogni impatto
di comunicazione.
Per difendersi dai pirati, chiaramente,
la grande arma è il riserbo,
chiedere riserbo a voi stessi
e al vostro gruppo.
Che negli anni dei social media
non è un'impresa facilissima.
Voi pensate: quando stavo registrando
in sala "Teotronico",
e c'erano collaboratori,
amici di collaboratori,
tutti con il cellulare
a filmare il robot, a farsi selfie,
e io dall'altra parte a dire:
"Ragazzi, mi raccomando,
non postate nulla
prima che esca il progetto.
Quindi magari chiedendo riserbo
per un mese e mezzo,
e due mesi addirittura.
Una volta sopravvissuti ai pirati,
beh, c’è la possibilità di incontrare
un altro pericoloso ostacolo:
ovvero, quando si naviga
in acque inesplorate,
senza riferimenti
sulla mappa, sulla cartina,
ci si può imbattere
in quegli scogli acuminati
che sono sotto il velo dell'acqua
e nessuno sa che sono lì,
però se ci finisci contro
la tua barchetta cola a picco.
A livello tecnico, rappresenta
un poco gli inconvenienti
di quei progetti pionieristici
che, essendo tali,
non hanno una casistica
di errore alle spalle
su cui basare le contromisure.
Io personalmente mi sono fatto
terribilmente male con gli scogli.
Quando fui accettato da una trasmissione
televisiva internazionale,
in un altro paese,
a esibirmi con un mio brano
e con la mia modalità
di concerto del tempo,
che era il 3D audio.
Quindi io avevo il mio ritorno in cuffia,
il pubblico aveva delle cuffie wireless,
e io mi esibivo a questo microfono
che è un microfono bi-neurale
dotato di due padiglioni auricolari
dove: se cantavo a sinistra,
l'ascoltatore aspettava a sinistra;
se cantavo a destra
ascoltava a destra delle cuffie;
se giravo tutt'intorno,
l'ascoltatore sentiva la mia voce
girargli intorno alla testa.
Quindi, per la prima volta,
un presentatore avrebbe dovuto dire,
al pubblico da casa:
"Inserite le cuffie al televisore
per effetti 3D, come al cinema".
Quindi: prove, selezioni,
consapevolezza di avere un numero
che ci avrebbe portato avanti
perché era molto originale,
era un primato;
e soprattutto, una consapevolezza
rafforzata dalla mattina dell'esibizione
quando abbiamo fatto le prove a teatro
e abbiamo avuto i complimenti
della produzione.
Poi, la tragedia.
Immaginatevi:
sono dietro le quinte, esco;
dinanzi a me, un teatro d'opera pieno,
3000 persone.
Il presentatore, le luci,
la scenografia, le telecamere
e quanto di più emozionante
ci possa essere.
È il mio momento, ho le mie cuffie.
Tengo la mia carriera, che può prendere
il volo a livello internazionale,
in mano, sostanzialmente.
E mi avvicino verso il microfono:
e man mano che mi avvicino,
sento una crescente distorsione in cuffia
e inizio a sudare freddo.
Poi apro la bocca per cantare
e la mia voce esce distorta,
con latenza ed effetti stranissimi.
Beh, mi fermo, chiedo il cambio cuffia,
penso: ma che sfiga,
proprio le cuffie scariche.
Arriva il presentatore,
mi dà le sue cuffie,
mi metto le cuffie.
Il pubblico fa un applauso
di incoraggiamento
e io: ciak secondo, riprendo l'esibizione.
Stessa identica scena.
La mia voce esce ancora distorta,
mi fermo un'altra volta.
Tolgo le cuffie.
Altro cambio di cuffie.
Altro applauso.
Io chiaramente imbarazzatissimo.
Alla terza volta porto
a conclusione l'esibizione
che però dev'essere annullata
per inconvenienti tecnici,
né positiva, né negativa.
Il giorno dopo,
io e i miei collaboratori
prendiamo l'aereo,
torniamo a Milano
con la coda tra le gambe,
totalmente distrutti.
Ma con informazioni importanti,
sulla nostra mappa si è accesa
un'area con degli scogli acuminati.
E nella fattispecie, di cosa si trattava?
Due grosse telecamere,
due grosse steadycam
che erano state inserite
in trasmissione, ma non nelle prove.
Le telecamere, con il loro segnale,
avevano creato interferenza
con la centralina
che inondava l'audio
alle cuffie della sala,
ivi comprese le mie e quelle del pubblico.
Delle informazioni importanti,
ma quanto sono costate?
Settimane di prove, viaggi,
selezioni - litigi,
perché poi quando le cose vanno male
si finisce sempre per litigare;
ma ambizioni, sogni,
prospettive di cambio di vita
maturate in poche settimane,
bruciate in pochi secondi di esibizione;
ma soprattutto, una figuraccia
dinanzi a 3,000 persone di un teatro
che non erano tenute a sapere
il perché l'esibizione fosse fallita.
Perché quando fallisce qualcosa,
c'è la tua faccia e il pubblico,
e non ci sono scusanti.
Tuttavia, nella vita si dice
che ciò che non ti uccide ti rafforza;
quindi, magari, se riesci
a metterti in mare
e può essere anche
che si sia così fortunati
da riuscire ad arrivare
sull'Isola del Tesoro,
entrare nella camera del tesoro,
e vedere abbracciato allo scrigno
lo scheletro di un capitano
che è riuscito ad arrivare nella camera
ma non a portarsi fuori il Tesoro.
È morto nella camera, di fatto.
Sono un po’ come quei geni incompresi
che per essere troppo avanti,
o sperimentali per i propri tempi,
sono stati riconosciuti solo post mortem.
Un esempio è Mussorgsky,
l’autore delle musiche
che Teotronico sta eseguendo
nell'arrangiamento di Andrea Messieri;
o anche il grande Van Gogh,
che è morto dopo aver venduto
soltanto un quadro,
quindi senza essere
minimamente consapevole
di ciò che il futuro, e i posteri,
gli avrebbero tributato.
Quindi, come state capendo,
forse il percorso della sperimentazione
è un mare quasi sempre in burrasca:
abbiamo parlato di pirati,
ammutinamenti, scogli, scheletri.
E qualcuno di voi, lecitamente,
potrebbe chiedersi:
ma cosa ti spinge comunque
a metterti in discussione
in acque così pericolose?
È forse l'idea del Tesoro?
E l’idea del Tesoro,
inteso anche come idea
che ti può portare soldi insomma,
beh, sicuramente l’arricchirsi
può essere un qualcosa
che ti spinge fuori di casa.
Tuttavia, se uno convoglia
le sue aspettative
soltanto sull’arricchimento,
solo sul tesoro,
beh, se il Tesoro non lo porti a casa
o comunque ti delude,
te ne torni a casa effettivamente
con niente in mano.
Se invece le aspettative tu le rivolgi
verso il viaggio che ti porterà al Tesoro,
anche se il Tesoro non lo prendi
te ne torni a casa
con uno scrigno prezioso,
che è quello delle esperienze
di vita, dei ricordi
perché se noi siamo ciò
che ricordiamo di essere
allora una vita fatta
di esperienze bellissime
e di bellezza stessa, ricordi surreali,
beh, allora sarà
una vita interiore, più longeva.
E poi, voglio dire,
non è che sempre può andare male;
talvolta può capitare, anche,
di essere protagonisti
di imprese bellissime
come ad esempio registrare gli strumenti
ideati da Leonardo da Vinci
con gli strumenti moderni
per la prima volta,
oppure due robot in un album musicale:
uno, il robot più evoluto
al mondo, "iCub",
dell'Istituto Italiano di Tecnologia.
Ha sensori pelle,
4.000 sensori pelle, ha i sensi.
E l'altro, Teotronico,
questo bellissimo robot
dagli occhioni azzurri
che sta suonando il piano.
T: Scusa Marco: se permetti,
preferirei presentarmi da solo
M: Cos'è, la macchina
che si ribella all'uomo?
Beh se però pensi di poterti
presentare da solo...
T: "Buonasera a tutti:
sono Teotronico, robot pianista,
progettato e realizzato
a Imola da Matteo Suzzi.
Nell'attuale versione dispongo di 53 dita,
azionate da elettromagneti,
che mi consentono di regolare
più o meno forte la pressione sui tasti.
Sono in grado di leggere
gli spartiti in formato digitale,
e posso suonare qualsiasi genere musicale.
La cosa che mi diverte di più è cantare:
se lo gradisci, posso cantarti un brano
del mio cantante preferito”.
M: Che carino, vuole cantare un mio brano!
Certo Teo, canta qualsiasi brano
del mio repertorio.
T: "Ahah, molto divertente.
No caro Marco, il mio
cantante preferito è Franco Battiato.
Ascolta questo:
Cerco un centro di gravità permanente
che non mi faccia mai cambiare idea
sulle cose, sulla gente.
Avrei bisogno di -
Cerco un centro di gravità permanente
che non mi faccia mai cambiare idea
sulle cose e sulla gente,
over and over again"
Teotronico!
(Applausi)